[Musique]
la recentralisation du rsa pour 1er
janvier 2020 redéfini le cadre
budgétaire du département une action
publique transformée converti en
trajectoire écologique et solidaire
les orientations budgétaires 2020 porté
par le département repose sur une valeur
forte la solidarité avec un taux de
pauvreté de près de 40% et avec 35% des
jeunes de 16 à 24 ans sans emploi ni
formation
la précarité touche en grande partie la
société réunionnaise
dans ces conditions l'action sociale est
indispensable chef de file de cette
action le département s'engage à
prévenir et lutter contre la pauvreté
renforcer l'accompagnement
responsabilisant des familles prévenir
et accompagner la perte d'autonomie des
publics sensibles et construire des
parcours d'insertion pour les publics en
difficulté pour faire face à
l'accélération du vieillissement de la
population le département érige le plan
senior
et pour répondre à la demande de
personnel qualifié pour la prise en
charge des personnes âgées
la collectivité met en place le cfa est
sapée centre de formation
d'apprentissage des services à la
personne
un dispositif qui s'adresse aux aidants
familiaux aux jeunes demandeurs d'emploi
et aux bénéficiaires du rsa
avec un taux de chômage élevé à la
réunion atteignant les 24 % le
département et l'état s'engage dans la
mise en place du plan pétrels priorités
et rassemblements pour l'emploi local à
la réunion la collectivité innove et
conforte ses dispositifs favorisant des
parcours d'insertion pour les publics en
difficulté avec la mise en place d'un
nouveau dispositif d'incitation à la
reprise d'activité pour les
bénéficiaires du rsa
la création d'une académie des dalons
dans l'est elle maintiendra les
dispositifs comme le tremplin pour
l'activité des jeunes
le challenge des créateurs elle
favorisera la mobilité et la coopération
avec les pays dans la zone océan indien
elle maintiendra les contrats aidés les
missions de service civique et les
ateliers et chantiers d'insertion des
mesures d'accompagnement
réalisé en partenariat avec le tissu
associatif local
[Musique]
le développement et l'aménagement du
territoire sont également des enjeux
majeurs de solidarité et plus
particulièrement en faveur des communes
les projets structurants comme la route
des eaux de l'est le développement des
périmètres irrigués et le grand projet
mais rennes seront poursuivis la
sécurisation et le développement des
axes routiers sont programmés et aménagé
dans le temps des études portant sur le
développement économique et social des
hauts de l'île sont réalisées comme le
projet de désenclavement du cirque de
salazie
cette solidarité territoriale s'inscrit
dans la concertation avec l'ensemble des
communes de l'île dans le cadre des pst
lé pacte de solidarité territoriale
[Musique]
la solidarité écologique est au coeur de
l'engagement pris par le département
dans la trajectoire outre-mer 5.00
exclusion zéro carbone zéro déchet zéro
polluants agricoles et 0 vulnérabilité
en 2020 700 hectares d'espacés naturels
seront restaurés la collectivité
s'engage dans un vaste plan de
reboisement avec la plantation d'un
million d'arbres d'espèces indigènes et
endémiques sur le territoire d'ici à
2024 avec le plan agri pays 2030 le
département pose les bases d'un modèle
agricole pour notre territoire
reconquérir les terres en friche
moderniser les exploitations diversifier
les productions et favoriser les
circuits courts
autant dax le développement pour une
agriculture réunionnaise durable
le département contribue également à
l'épanouissement des hommes et des
femmes par le sport la culture et
l'éducation la collectivité soutient les
associations sportives les sportifs de
haut niveau et partage la culture pour
la diffuser au plus grand nombre
l'accompagnement des soixante mille
collégiens au sein des 83 collèges de
l'île conduit la collectivité a optimisé
ses politiques éducatives et les
parcours de réussite
les orientations budgétaires 2020
présentée par le département porte la
vision d'une société réunionnaise
solidaire soucieuse de son
épanouissement humain et respectueuse de
la préservation de son environnement
[Musique]